the nation is marking its newest
national holiday today juneteenth
president biden signed legislation this
week making the day a federal holiday
it commemorates the events of june 19
1865
when union soldiers brought news to
enslave black people in galveston texas
that they were free
many large corporations including viacom
cbs recognized juneteenth on friday with
moments of silence early closures
or a payday off for employees but to
many the day represents
much more than that christina rafini is
at the white house with more on this
christina good morning to you
good morning jeff you know this holiday
came about so quickly
that the post office is actually still
delivering mail and that's because it
said it couldn't stop service that fast
but for people who've been fighting for
recognition of this day for generations
it didn't feel fast
it felt long overdue
from a june team flag raising in boston
this is an amazing day
in our city to a march in saint paul
americans celebrated their first new
federal holiday in 36 years
also known as jubilee day and black
independence day
juneteenth marks the moment in 1865
when two months after the end of the
civil war
union troops finally got all the way to
texas to tell the enslaved people there
they were free
this is one of the ways to acknowledge
that our ancestors
weren't free for two and a half years
after the emancipation proclamation
old opal lee has been fighting for
federal recognition of juneteenth for
decades
you are an incredible woman is opal you
really are she got a front row seat when
the president signed the bipartisan bill
and one of his pens but she says the
fight isn't over
we've still got much work to do
and we see this is a
great beginning advocates argue that
work includes
passing federal voting rights
legislation currently stalled in
congress
to protect against new restrictive
voting laws in states like florida and
georgia
that critics say disproportionately
impact people of color
we are talking about the preservation of
a right that is the right of citizenship
and a police reform bill which president
biden encouraged lawmakers to pass
in april during his speech to a joint
session of congress
but let's get it done next month by the
first anniversary of george floyd's
death
but that anniversary came and went
without congressional action
now the government was closed yesterday
since this year the 19th was on a
weekend but today is the actual holiday
so expect to see more of those
celebrations and commemorations across
the country
a lot of them will be taking place
i'll be at one of them thank you so much
christina well